- Seriously where
is the bathroom?
- The bathroom is downstairs.
- It is downstairs?
- It's downstairs.
- And it's good for both?
- Yes, there's both.
- Okay, great.
- Bye buddy.
- Did he mean both pee and poop?
- Hey everyone, welcome
to "The Other Show."
We're talking about
episode eight today.
- And we are joined by
Drew and Helene, as always,
and Josh Segarra,
who plays Lance.
- What's up guys?
- Yeah!
- Hello!
- What about us?
- Hi, hello.
I didn't know if I was
allow to stand up in the ...
- I was so stressed to
high five on camera.
(laughter)
- Whoa!
Sick ride, baby!
- [Man] I got it for Chase.
I think he's wheely
gonna like it.
You know, 'cause the wheels.
(Lance laughs)
- Hi, Lance.
- Now, you guys knew each other?
- We've known each other
for a decade, yeah.
- Not super close, but man,
we've been buddies
ever since, man.
- [Chris] Just from the
theatre world, right?
'Cause you do
Broadway too, yeah.
- Because we do the theater,
Josh and I know each other.
- Our show has so many
Broadway people in it.
- Really trained people
- And Drew.
- And then Drew.
- I've never seen a stage.
- He's never seen a Broadway
show, you've never gone-
- Don't like plays.
I hate 'em.
- You saw Angels in
America Part One.
Did you see the second part?
- I still haven't seen it.
- He came to set and was like,
"I'm gonna go see
the second part,"
we were like, "Mm-hmm."
- Still hasn't seen
it as if it's running
and it's a possibility.
(Drew laughs loudly)
- What are you doing here?
- Oh, um.
Sex?
- Hell yeah.
That's what I'm talkin about.
- Here's a weird thing
we just remembered
is that you auditioned for a
thousand different
roles, didn't you?
- I did.
- Sorry.
- No way, that was
awesome though!
Those are days that
actors remember.
You kidding me?
Now that it worked out this way.
I remember that day for sure.
I read three different parts.
- Do you remember-
- It was the flight attendant,
then it was the roommate,
and that was hilarious 'cause
now I know what happens.
And that's super fun, right?
Imagine that all the time
and that would've
been very fun, buddy.
(laughing)
- Then they said,
"Hey man, you wanna come
play with this one?"
I said, "Heck yeah,
I love this guy."
And it was awesome, man.
- We basically had to
make it fit you better.
So we spent a little
time with you,
started hearing
the words you said.
Like: oh hell yeah.
(laughing)
And that became a part...
Your voice became a
part of the character-
- I don't know why you're
lying on camera, Sarah,
because we all know that
Lance is your spirit animal.
Lance has lived inside
of you for years.
- Once I found it,
it really came-
- I remember going up to you
on set on night and saying
"Can you say, 'Oh
hell yeah,' here?"
and you said, "Oh hell yeah."
(laughing)
- No! Gimme that. Give
it. Absolutely not.
Not drinking alcohol tonight.
You're 14.
Plus you're contractually
obligated to drink Voss.
- What did you do for your
birthdays when you were little?
- So in Orlando,
where I grew up,
for many years we
went to this resort.
So I remember, it's
either my 13th or 14th,
and I remember men,
just beautiful men, in Speedos.
And I remember this pool being
like, "This is the best!"
An arcade, they had
WrestleFest, the video game.
They had an indoor pool,
outdoor pool, but men!
So we go to the
top of the slide,
and I meet two men!
Gorgeous men.
And I say, "Guys, what's
going on here, man?"
And it's the first time
I learned what Pride was.
Pride is the weekend of June,
and they were holding
Pride at that resort.
And I was also
having my birthday.
- So for your 13th
birthday you went to Pride.
- Pride at a pool with
a slide, an arcade.
- That's great.
- And I made some
of the best friends.
- Wow!
We grew up differently.
(laughing)
- Hey, did he puke
on my back at all?
- Barely.
Well, a lot. He puked a lot.
- Yeah, I could feel it.
- This is the episode
where these two characters
reconnect, Brooke and Lance.
And we really, when
we were writing it,
we were just like, what are...
Almost leaning into
the rom-comness of it
A little bit of...
What are these iconic
places we can put them in?
One of them was on the bridge.
On the Brooklyn Bridge.
We had to shoot...
We had to shut down
small part of the bridge
and redirect tourists
who were very eager
to see who was shooting and then
they didn't really care.
(laughing)
- They liked Case though!
Case got stopped many times!
- Case got recognized.
- Case would get
stopped sometimes.
- A couple times filming,
people would come up
to me and be like, "Who's
filming over there?"
And I'd be like, "Uh, me."
(laughing)
"It's me."
- To take it down,
you think like,
"I wanna be on a tv show."
Then you're closing off
parts of the Brooklyn Bridge.
You're there waiting
for the sun to go down,
and you're like, "Whoa!"
It was crazy.
- That was such a special...
The scene watching
those characters have
separated from each other.
You watched him help
your little brother,
and that is, I think,
something a lot of us
can relate to with
past relationships
is they become a
part of your family.
- Of course.
- I think that she
thought that her life
was gonna be this
big thing, and then
she is faced with this
person who is a part of it,
and she's like, "I
don't need this."
Then realizes how important
those simple things are
and that kind of a connection.
- And not to be too dramatic
'cause this is a comedy thing,
but we did talk about,
'cause we both have
a parent who died,
and we talked about
relating to having an ex
that knew our parent
and then being like,
we're breaking up with them,
but you still feel a
connection because you're like,
they knew me when I was
then or they knew them.
- And they were there with
me while that was happening.
- So we liked that about
your character in the season.
That you're
introduced as a dummy,
or introduced as a comic relief,
or as like a this guy.
But humanizing him throughout
and seeing that he is
a solid person, he is
like a rock and he is like
feels like home.
- Home to her.
- It's even like on the bridge,
he says something about
his mom's friend's Connie.
- You just know
there's a shorthand.
- That you know who Connie is.
- In the middle of laughter
you see two people connect.
Taking care of their
younger brother.
- Totally.
- It's very easy to stay
on the surface stuff,
but you get down to it,
that's why this thing is cool.
That's why I'm happy to be here.
- That's nice.
- Heavy.